why hello there
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for today may 13
20 21 and before we do anything else
just a quick reminder to have you guys
subscribe to our youtube channel
tap that notification bell and maybe
just maybe you'll see our videos in your
feed i can't guarantee it but hey
it's worth a shot right today we are
doing a
ask me anything q a we took a ton of
questions from rubenreport.locals.com so
feel free to join over there if you ever
want to get in on our thursday ask me
anythings
and i'm going to hit up one story before
we do all that because
as we've talked about a lot i think it's
a lot officially
wokism is pretty much destroying
everything and it's destroying the very
industries that brought it into the
system in the first place in this
specific case i'm talking about
hollywood
because there ain't gonna be no golden
globes this year
because of all that racist stuff so
we're gonna talk about that
and then get to as many questions as
possible but before all that i want to
talk to you guys about ancestry.com you
know there are many paths
to finding your family story whichever
way you choose
tracing your family generations back
with a family tree or uncovering your
ethnicity with ancestry dna
it's easy to get started with ancestry
you could find a famous relative or
perhaps a photo
of your great grandma as a little girl
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history and yourself
after all the story of your family is
the story of you
this past year has made many of us feel
disconnected from our loved ones
fortunately researching your history is
a fun activity the whole family can
enjoy
even when separated by distance and the
stories you learn about your shared past
can bring you closer together
ancestry dna can reveal ethnic origins
and provide historical details that
bring unique family stories to life
ancestry dna doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from but can also
pinpoint the specific
regions within them giving you
insightful geographic details
about your history trace the paths of
your recent ancestors
and learn how and why your family moved
from place to place
around the world no other dna test
delivers such a unique interactive
experience
grab an ancestry dna kit and start a
free trial to amplify your discoveries
with ancestry's billions of records
start exploring your family history
today head to my url at ancestry.com
reuben to get your ancestry dna kit and
start your free trial
that's ancestry.com reuben and now back
to me
all right let's talk about the golden
globes we've got a tweet here from axios
quote
nbc says it won't air the golden globes
next year
over criticisms that the hollywood
foreign press association
is not sufficiently committed to
diversity oh you can never be woke
enough for the woksters
we've got some quotes from nbc we
continue to believe that the hollywood
foreign press association is committed
to meaningful reform however change of
this magnitude takes
time and work and we feel strongly that
the hfpa needs time to do it right
as such nbc will not air the 2022
golden globes assuming the organization
executes on its plan we are hopeful
we'll be in a position to air
the show in january 2023
uh for god's sake so this is just
hollywood eating itself
and although with all due irony as i sit
here in los angeles
uh i have to say i'm sort of enjoying it
i mean this is what you get at the end
of wokism
everything is racist everything must be
destroyed it's time to take everything
out
as you guys know the oscars were just in
the last couple of weeks or maybe you
don't know it because basically nobody
watched less than 10
million people watched the oscars when
was the last time you saw a good new
movie you know there's a couple tv shows
that trickle out on some of these
streaming services on top of the fact
that you know kovid caused all these
shutdowns so there's just way less
stuff out there it's like all i watch
basically are they saying i watch the
same things that i watched
in 1989 i watch seinfeld i watch the
simpsons and i watch golden girls that's
that's pretty much good enough for me
i'm also watching handmaid's tale it's
not bad
it's not bad but they got the whole
thing wrong although all the wokesters
thought that the bad guys
were like the trump people and no it's
just actually completely reverse
um anyway seeing these things crumble
it's just so consistent with
everything that the modern left does
they are here
to crush everything and how are we to
believe that the hollywood foreign press
is a
is a racist organization the idea that
they can't get their awards show in
order
because they have to get more black
people in like they are the ones
ushering in the systemic racism we have
to get more quotas in guys we can't give
all the awards to white men and we've
got to make sure more black women get it
and trans people and people with a bad
hip and a lazy eye
it's just endless stupidity and it will
continue
all right let's get away from stupidity
and let's go to the questions patrick
says
dave you have talked about inc the
increasing divergence between red and
blue states
if this trend continues could it result
in the fragmentation of the u.s
similar to what happened to the ussr
where some
former soviet republics are democracies
while others
are dictatorial hellholes sounds
outlandish but outlandish things are
already happening
you know there was a long while i would
say about a year where i was starting to
think about
some of this stuff probably even more
than a year actually and then of course
you know kovid just completely blew that
thing open because the radical
difference between
lockdowns and states that were basically
left free and crushing people's jobs
and now we're seeing just the growth of
the state that we're going to give
people unemployment forever and
all of the stuff that you guys all know
and while i was thinking about that for
a year a year and a half maybe even
more i didn't want to bring it up that
often because i don't like the idea of
like adding to the
it feels like it's like adding to the
embers of the fire in a way you know
what i mean like it feels like oh if we
talk about this stuff some of it'll just
we'll we'll will it into being i want
the united states
to remain the united states right the
the founders had such a brilliant idea
that you could live in
these geographic places that would be
very different from each other but we
would
what would bring us together with the
ideas of freedom and liberty and that
if there was a place that was more in
line with whatever your belief system
was
religiously or whatever your belief
system was economically or
philosophically whatever it was
you could find a place to be so in many
ways what's happening right now
where you see places that are much more
in line with say what i believe so let's
talk about obviously florida
and texas and tennessee i mean if you
would have ever said to me 20 years ago
that's what i'd be saying now
i think the world was upside down but i
guess the world is upside down um the
fact that they are doing what they think
is right
related to lockdowns and everything else
is great and then of course you
in my opinion it's great and then of
course you've got places like new york
and california
that are that are in my opinion doing
much worse things well we know they
actually just released a study that
california this year
had their first net loss of people
meaning more people moved out of
california
than moved in first time in the history
of california so people are waking up so
i would say
this is what the founders sort of
envisioned in a way and and the real
question will be
is will the federal government keep
becoming so big that it will start
infringing on the rights of those states
you know i've joked about it but it's
like florida should build a freaking
wall
and get that get that you know national
guard armed up
because the the federal government will
infringe on that they're not just gonna
let people
roam free in the free state of florida
so i'm slightly kidding about a wall
and an army slightly but it's like the
states are gonna have to really figure
out
how to defend what it is that they
believe
in those states and the laws that they
pass and defend their citizens and
everything else
because the federal government's
completely out of control and the blue
states are just
patently ridiculous at this point
stephen
asks do you feel more and more blue team
people
are waking up and fed up with the
mandates overreach and woke politics
california
i think in reality yes everyone is sick
of this woke thing
and we know it statistically and it's
weird that it doesn't fully show up
in in voting but like what is possibly
left of the democratic party
show me someone on the democratic side
of things that is that is against
woke-ism really fighting it someone that
is against identity politics
the democrats literally in a completely
partisan vote
voted to continue to allow uh
colleges to discriminate against asian
people every single democratic senator
voted for it
right if you're asian how in the world
could you be a democrat at this point
if you have half a brain and that that's
not to say that you should be a
republican like i'm not saying that and
i don't think the republicans are that
great but they're better than that thing
right like we all know they're better
than that so are more people waking up i
think
people are like if your takeaway in the
past year of lockdowns and everything
else regardless of what you feel about
like some of these
specific political issues but if your
takeaway of the last year was yes we
need
more government if only government would
do more for us if only those people had
more power things would be better
then then i don't know you need some
kind of psychological evaluation i would
say more than
more than a political uh class you need
to really
look at why you look at the world in
such a backwards way so i do think a lot
of people have been red pilled in that
regard and the question is
will will they vote that way and will
all the people fleeing the blue states
into the red states will they finally
realize that they had a little something
to do
with this disaster and will they vote
accordingly alicia
says i know you went to college in this
environment do you think it's worth
going as a conservative
and either speaking up or just quietly
passing classes
do you see any future for people who
work to prove
their competence in manners other than
college attendance
i look we're working out having kids
right now so that means i'm not going to
have kids for a long time i'm going to
be at old timer i'm going to be i'm
going to be an old father
however the idea that it's like you know
18 years from now or so i'm going to
send my kids to college
if by college or university we mean
anything close
to what exists right now you're
basically sending young people to a
brainwashing institution
that is pretty much it when bernie says
we want free college forever and
he knows that's the best place to get
brainwashed
socialists it's not because he wants
them to learn something
from thomas soul or libertarian
economics or even that the history of
the united states was good but
all of the stuff that's leaking out into
society ever it started on the college
campuses we all know this
it's partly why i was ahead of the game
on all of this stuff because five years
ago
if not more i was speaking at college
campuses and i saw
all of this craziness and i was like
wait a minute these kids are going to
get out into the real world and they're
being taught by these
awful people and and what's been strange
is you know there were all the people
that said oh
once they're out in the real world
they'll they'll fall into line you know
the real world or get them and
but the real world just kind of
collapsed they just ran right over it
so i think there's probably a gajillion
ways to think about
educating yourself outside of college
the amount that you can learn
you know just listening to lectures on
youtube and then of course there's the
part of the college experience about
getting away from your parents
you know living with friends you know
living living somewhere say in between
you know high school and then fully as
adult
you know hopefully married with a family
like we could figure out what the social
things are with that should young people
live together differently in communal
things like i don't know
there's something we could figure out
about the social part of college that i
think is important
but the idea that you'd spent save 80
grand or something
as an adult to send your kid to one of
these places where they're most likely
going to learn that you're evil and
everything you've done for them is
horrible and the country is terrible
is a bad idea how about just give them
that cash and help them get out
on the world without debt and help them
put the down payment on a house or car
or whatever else
michael says it appears that much of
what we're seeing take place within the
leftist controlled government
is not incompetence but a well executed
example
of the cloud pivot strategy laid out in
the 1960s
modified for current politics thoughts
so without going too much into the
specifics on this
the the question really is is this all
happening by accident or is this a plan
it feels very much like a plan to me
um who was the the russian former kgb
agent yuri bez
give me the last name yuri besmanov um
slightly butchering it
we'll get it for you in just a sec who
who talked about
how you would instill uh communism
basically in the united states and that
you could take
out a free country like the united
states without ever having to fire
a bullet because you would do it through
the inside um we just had his name there
yuri besmanov is his name and you should
check out the youtube videos of him
from literally i think they're from 30
or 40 years ago and they're absolutely
fascinating and lay out exactly
kind of what's happening here so i think
there there is a strategy none of this
feels organic to me it feels very
coordinated with big tech and what
trends and what
doesn't and then the way the media only
covers things if it
covers issues when they fit their racial
narrative and they don't cover
the other things when they don't and the
way that nba players like lebron james
fall into line but won't say anything
about china it all feels like part of a
pattern
and it's like what is that like what is
that whole thing
i don't know it's almost like asking
what the meaning of life is like you can
just sort of see what you see
and figure out how to how to act
accordingly within it i think that's the
best thing that you can do
uh leo says thoughts on biden's first
hundred days where did he go wrong and
what
and did he do anything right i mean i
think they've been pretty much a
disaster
on all fronts like there was no healing
there is no unity
you know gas prices are going through
the roof we're actually having gas
shortages
right now that they're not really
covering on mainstream media but it is
happening
um the middle east is on fire again it
was basically peaceful not basically it
was peaceful and there were at least
five peace deals signed under trump but
now the the bad actors now realize they
can start doing stuff again
so we've got we've got war on the
horizon you can sort of feel it
we've got gas shortages there we don't
have any of that unity we have a media
that is completely emboldened to hide
everything
that the democrats do where we know if
trump you know
farted the wrong way they would have
done three weeks worth of coverage on it
i don't know that you can fart a right
way but you see my point um
so i don't know there's i think the the
modern democratic party has been
completely decimated and is basically
a radical extremist leftist organization
i don't know how to say it any
differently
and it's very sad to me that my liberal
friends didn't see this coming because i
thought it was
pretty obvious and and believe me if
there was something to give this guy
credit on
i would love to find it but i don't know
what it is do you feel confident
that we will get through lockdowns and
not have more lockdowns when he's saying
oh
you know remember two months ago it was
oh you can get together in july and now
it's like well we'll see what happens in
july
these people just want more and more and
more and more and they're just going to
keep taking it as long as you give it to
them
elijah says what do you make of the
situation in israel
at the moment so look there's a barrage
of rockets coming from gaza hitting tel
aviv hitting jerusalem hitting well
basically all over israel
first off i would say if you if you have
no nothing you know a lot of people
whenever you bring up the middle east
say i know nothing about it like
you know what what do we do i would say
first look at a map
look at a map so israel is obscenely
tiny
to the point that it's basically the
size of new jersey in a pretty
in a pretty rough neighborhood right and
israel is by far
the country in the middle east with the
most diversity meaning that there are
arabs and jews and christians who get
along
i've been there many times i've been to
jerusalem where you can
within moments of each other walk to the
church of the holy sepulchre which is
the holiest site in christianity
to the western wall which is the holiest
site in judaism to the dome of the rock
which is the second
or third holiest site in islam which is
built on top of the decimated jewish
temple the temple mount there was a
temple there
now all the jews have left is is a wall
um
but there is diversity there you can see
women walking around in burqas
next to ultra-orthodox jewish men in
black hats like there is no place
in the middle east that is freer and
lets their citizens vote and all of
those things
that's not to say that any country
doesn't have its flaws they all do
but i would say this that every single
country on earth
has the the right and i would say the
duty to defend its citizens as
it sees fit and i'm fairly certain that
if a whole bunch of
rockets were coming from canada and
hitting us in detroit we'd probably bomb
mexico
so every country has a right to defend
itself so israel's got the iron dome
which is blowing these rockets out of
the air
we know that hamas shoots the rockets
from hospitals and from children's
playgrounds because they want
dead palestinians that's just their
cynical view of the world
they want dead arabs because then that
they think that that will turn the world
against israel
and and then also learn a little bit of
history
about all of this there was never a
nation known
as palestine meaning a palestinian
people the the arab nations used to
boycott palestine which was the
the british mandate of palestine after
the ottoman empire so it was turkish
during the ottoman empire then it was
british then they said okay we're going
to split these things up the jews said
yes in 47 the arabs said no
then they all attacked they lost a war
they're still upset about that war
that's what this is really
all about and you know the west bank
used to be part
of jordan and gaza used to be part of
egypt they don't want it anymore
but there was never there was no
palestinian who was the prime minister
like
there wasn't there just wasn't you can
read your old new york times when it was
sort of a newspaper
articles in the 30s and 40s that the
arab states were boycotting palestine
because that's where the jews lived
anyway i could do this forever it starts
becoming like a little
a little it becomes like some long thing
that you got to talk about
in great detail um but also you know i
saw this
these ridiculous tweets from ilhan omar
who's just absolutely awful
and you know basically calling israel a
terrorist state and it's like
her buddy rashida talib on one hand you
wish jews happy hanukkah and then at the
same time you know hanukkah is the story
of the jews defending the
judean hills you're not going to believe
what judean means
uh rasheeda and where are those hills oh
they're in the west bank
so that holiday the jews celebrate for 5
000 something years
has something to do with jews living in
that place that you don't want any jews
to live in or that jesus guy
remember jesus he lived in bethlehem
that's also in the west bank so jews
must have lived there
a long time too i mean these the
hypocrisy
is just off the charts but we're
removing any of all of that i would say
every nation has a right to defend
itself so israel can defend itself and
if and if you're
for hamas then they can defend
themselves and if you think if you
believe that hamas firing rockets is
some way defending themselves
then i think i think you're just sorely
mistaken but everybody can defend
themselves
as they see fit but i don't think that
there would be any nation that would be
more restrained than israel at the
moment probably to a fault actually
ben says i've been watching bill maher
for the last few months to get out of my
conservative echo chamber
there's times when he seems to get it
but always follows up
with uh with vote democrat which makes
me want to scream do you think he'll
ever have that moment where he realizes
democrats
are the anti-reality party if you do do
you think he'll accept it
when it happens so first off i just want
to put this out there i was booked on
the show twice and they canceled on me
twice
one was kobit related when my book came
out and then there was one other time
i would be happy to go on the show i
would be happy to have uh have bill here
literally in my house or we could do it
via skype
i would say that bill
in essence is an old school liberal who
maybe hasn't quite been mugged by
reality yet because he's just so
rich so he thinks he can kind of get
away with it something like that and i
don't even mean that to be a dick
like he's a single lifelong bachelor
atheist like you're a
so he can just like have all his ideas
that
sort of makes sense in his liberal world
view that don't have any concrete
reality anymore but if he wants to live
free if you think
that the democrats in the left are the
party and the political ideology that
makes sense to you
that just doesn't make sense to me
anymore but does he get some things
right which is your point yes he's
pretty good on the free speech stuff
like he really is like i i think and he
does call out both sides when he can
um but you know the example i always
bring up is he had adam schiff our
moronic
you know representative from california
from the bay area who was the lead
you know lead guy during the trump the
first trump impeachment before the
second champion peach bit
and he had adam schiff on and he's
complaining to adam schiff about how
high taxes are and regulations are high
and all his friends are leaving
and it's like he can't put it together
that it's because well bill you support
democrats
these are the people that run this state
and if you think all of the things are
bad in this state and you do complain
about
how bad education is and you do complain
about the drug problem
even though i think bill's answer would
be to legalize more drugs which i don't
think is the
totally right answer but you complain
about high taxes and all
all the people fleeing but then your
answer is always okay keep voting in the
same people so i think bill is
actually a libertarian and at this point
i would say he's a conservative in that
new way that i've been talking about
conservative
but he can't say it because it's like
his whole audience will turn on him and
the guy's you know he's at the end of
his career you know he could go on for a
couple years obviously but like
he's sort of at the end and it's like at
the end are you going to really make a
stand
actually that would be the honorable
cool thing to do and i would love to
i would love it like i actually think it
would be awesome if if he would start
really saying it as it is um but you
know he's a tv host and
it is what it is and i say that as a
youtuber oscar says there's a lot of
people on the right and in the media who
have a lot to say about what the harris
biden team is doing wrong and how it's
destroying america
what is some actionable advice that you
and your guests could give us to
individually counter the deterioration
of america
under this administration start caring
about
local elections know who your
congressman is
like that kind of stuff like right now
here in l.a like our roads are gross
there's homelessness everywhere
encampments all of these things like i
don't expect joe biden to fix it i
actually don't expect my democratic
congressman to fix it either but we've
got a better chance to work on that guy
right so we've actually
been trying to make some contact over
there like that's the point
that's the point that you must have some
ability
to affect your life and and the way
we've outsourced all this
that the federal government should make
every decision for everybody whether you
live in downtown los angeles
or you live in you know rural
pennsylvania or something
um is actually crazy so i would say
that's the political level and then the
other part
is is the family level i would say at
the spiritual level something like that
like
like know what you believe do a little
bit of what jordan peterson was saying
in that video that we played a week or
so ago
about truth you know telling truth
telling the truth for truth's sake that
in some ways that's the ultimate
expression
of faith that if you just say i will
tell the truth and it doesn't mean that
everything will be right
but by putting truth out there that will
be better than all possible
uh you know alternatives like that seems
like something that gives us a little
power back to ourselves
so if the world is going to hell in a
hand basket it's like we don't have to
speed it up ourselves with lies
i don't know that there's much more that
we can do right now like the best you
can do i think is make your
family stronger your local community
stronger maybe vote for those people at
that level that can help you do it but i
don't think the answer is political
the fact that we think everything is
political is part of the problem in the
first place
james who is your favorite democrat well
all my favorite democrats are dead
but i would say jfk that's not what your
country can do for you ask what you can
do for your country that's reverse
bernie sanders
daniel patrick moynihan who i had the
pleasure of meeting who was a great
senator
a liberal democrat from new york uh
who was an incredible senator um who
fought for true liberalism which is
again his modern conservatism
was wonderful ed koch who was the mayor
of new york city
there there were some good democrats
like who now i mean
i guess tulsi gabbard but honestly i'm
not totally sure
that tulsi considers herself a democrat
anymore i don't want to put words in her
mouth or
uh or claim anything that that isn't
true
uh but look what the party did to her
here she was she was anti-war
she was anti-identity politics she was
for reaching across the aisle
right like think how differently imagine
if joe biden
you know uh imagine
if dementia ridden joe biden had chosen
tulsi gabbard instead of
uh harris kamala harris like where we
would be right now things could actually
be a little bit different but they went
all in on radicalism and centrism has
nothing to do with the democrats so
it'll be interesting i i'd love to
discuss that further
with tulsi like where does she shake out
on all of this
it's an interesting question but who's
my favorite democrat yeah they're all
gone
um debbie says are you still coming to
florida in june
hopefully orlando will be on the
schedule
so i had six stand-up shows and six
nights booked in the middle of june and
then a couple other important travel
things came up and we realized we looked
at the numbers
i will be totally honest with you
because i am trying to be totally honest
we looked at the numbers and the
schedule and it just like it didn't
really fully financially make sense
to step out of the studio for that long
and do it uh in
comedy clubs where there's only like 200
people there per gig
or whatever especially now because
they're still socially distanced and
some they're not at full capacity and
all that
so i want to do theater shows so we are
looking at a whole bunch of theater
shows
which we will start in florida for sure
and we're trying to figure that out
for the fall because by then every
everything should be fully open open
open
and then it will make sense to do um but
i will be in
florida uh june i think 17th to 19th
i'm interviewing the mayor of miami
who's doing a great job well he's
actually a democrat
mayor suarez is a democrat but he is
welcoming tech
to come to miami to build the future of
tech infrastructure it's really
beautiful thing
uh so i'll be interviewing him we're
either doing it at city hall or we may
be doing it on location somewhere
and maybe i can pull together you know
what we will pull together not maybe
i will do a locals event there for sure
so if you want to find out what we're
going to do
reubenport.locals.com oh he's a
republican
hot damn the one democrat i like is a
republican well there you go
sorry suarez sorry mayor suarez you are
a republican
i retract you're my favorite democrat
because you're a republican you've got
to love it i mean it doesn't get better
than that
otto says what is your favorite thing
about your career
um well i love this
right like i love the ability like it's
my this is what i do for a living i'm
able to tell you guys what i think and
be around good people and meet so many
cool people and travel and
and all of that but i guess more than
anything else like i've said this before
but it has something to do with the
purpose part of this
i wake up every day with purpose like
there is a reason to fight and i know
well i know we all have a reason to
fight but like i know that i can have
some influence in that
fight so even you know a couple days ago
when i
read you guys that that new york times
thing where
the reporter basically called me a white
supremacist and that i regularly have
white supremacists on and yang didn't
really
defend me or whatever it was like i woke
up and while in the old days that would
have angered me it kind of seemed funny
to me and then i was like
well okay this is what happened the new
york times is crap this is a journalist
not a journalist
like let's fight let me fight for what i
believe in and say what i believe
and get my voice out there and then of
course what happens is you guys back me
you watch this show you comment on
things you've joined us
on locals and like i've just had a great
community and
to the point of you know when we go down
to florida we'll do a locals meet up
like i've been doing these meetups in la
and we did in
there they've been oc and i've done one
in dallas and we're going to keep doing
them
it's like i'm meeting great people i
think you guys are way better
than our political class and uh so what
my favorite thing is
is people humans you guys yeah
tyler says if you had to live the rest
of your life without basketball or bbq
which would you choose well the answer
is obvious which is
bbq that's not a slight to basketball i
love basketball but as you know i've got
this torn acl i may have the surgery
this summer i'm actually leaning towards
it
because for the first time in the five
or six years that i've had this
this torn acl it's actually starting to
bother me and i was also thinking the
other day
you know if the zombie apocalypse comes
which it seems like it's getting closer
and closer
i'm gonna need to be able to run freely
you know what i mean i can't just
sit up on my porch up there and shoot
zombies all day like at some point
the zombies always break into the house
in which case i'm gonna need to be able
to run and the thing is when you have a
torn acl
you can run straight but you can't do
zigzags and i feel like there would be a
lot of zigzagging
if i was running away from zombies so
anyway i think i'm probably gonna get
the surgery sometime in july we shall
see and and the point is
i can't play basketball that many more
years even if i had a good knee
right like productive fun basketball i'd
play horse but barbecue
can last a lifetime so there you go uh
jamie says do you read fiction
if so what is your favorite novel or
classical
literature book i you know i don't have
time to read
in that sense anymore so i tell you guys
that when
when i have guests on in the old days at
the beginning of the show before i was
also running a tech company and had so
much going on i would always read the
book of the guest and then over the
years that's become less and less and
less and then sometimes now i
don't read any which i think sometimes
can make for a better interview
because i can ask more questions that
are
that are vague and open-ended let's say
and with less of my opinion in them so
that could be kind of good
sometimes i have to read a little bit
more sometimes my producer
michael gives me a recap of certain
things you know we try to play it by ear
depending on what the topic is who the
guest is
do i know them what type of interview e
are they etc etc
so unfortunately fiction books have
become
have really been pushed down because
most of the stuff that i'm
interviewing people about is non-fiction
however i will say this
pro this wasn't the last one i i read
but one
of the great fiction books that i've
read which is one of my favorite movies
also of all time
is the movie contact and a lot of times
you guys will ask me about
a book that i think you should read and
i always talk about billions and
billions which is
carl sagan who did cosmos of course it
was his last book he actually died
at the end before the book was finished
then his wife ann druyan who was also a
professor at cornell she ended up
finishing the book but carl sagan wrote
one fiction book and it was contact and
i'm sure many of you have seen the movie
with jody foster and matthew mcconaughey
that movie just blew my mind
opened me up to such a new world of
things i saw that in 97 i had eaten pot
brownies and we were going to see air
force one
and air force one was sold out and we
just go into contact we didn't know what
the hell it was me and my buddies
and that panorama of the universe comes
out and i'm stoned out of my mind and
that thing just
got me and just a great great movie
james woods is in it too
and then i ended up reading the book i
read all of sagan's books
that's his only non-fiction and in the
non-fiction one without getting too lost
in this you know
if you remember in contact she goes into
the machine alone
in the book several scientists go into
the machine and all have different
experiences so
there's it's just a great wonderful book
um
owen says are there any films you think
put out the same message
as the star wars prequels but are
actually good
films oh my god there there must be uh
well basically you're talking about the
this thing that i always talk about
which is the accumulation of power
creating a war to to in essence
shut down one of the sides when you have
enough power and then you're
the hegemonic power you are supreme
leader
you know your supreme chancellor
palpatine um
i don't know do you have any good ideas
on that one
if you're in you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of dystopian future kind
of things
yeah i don't know one that like
specifically that lev that level of
power kind of thing i'm not exactly sure
especially from a political perspective
which is why i love the the prequels as
much as i do
um i think that's it is that is that all
we're doing today was that the final
question
that was the final question guys uh part
two of my interview with nigel farage
is up on youtube right now and of course
you can watch the full thing
at reubenreport.locals.com
and our panel show tomorrow will be
travis brown
douglas murray and peter bogosian
they're doing a documentary
all on wokism how it's affecting the
colleges all the stuff that we're
constantly talking about here
from from two of my favorite people
douglas and peter and travis
is the one putting the doc together
thanks for watching everybody
see you tomorrow that's all
you